so this is the Tactical Operations
Center this is where you kick off
everything this is a secure area
underneath the base of operation okay so
no civilians only jtf only agents and
this is where you're going to be
collecting all the information that you
need to okay get a better picture of
what's happening what threats are coming
up from the underground awesome for
different difficulty levels including
heroic that's that serious business
there yes yannick told me before that
he's not super confident in his ability
on a console so is gonna yeah yeah take
it pretty easy first time but you know
he chose normal recommended gear score
12 they shouldn't have any problem with
it yes and I guess we're going directive
lyst the first time through directive
list the first time yeah
alright eating in my favor on this we've
never seen now what's happening like
this is not rehearse the pre-recorded
we're doing this right now and this
could be any type of a operation what
we're looking at here already is a
random element are we have critical
infrastructure as or objective Arkham
you didn't know that going into this
already we're having to react to you on
the ground gonna have to talk together
more as a group and take all the
Russell's above so your first objective
is to eliminate all of these hostiles
within this area yeah so you know to get
the protective critical infrastructure
we're gonna have to fight our way there
and that's exactly what's happening here
you know there are roving factions on
the ground you know they're plotting
attacks above ground and we're gonna
have to fight it's a struggle every step
of the way in the underground heiko
division fans will also see that Yannick
is using a new weapon and I'm not going
to go too in depth on that but that is a
completely new weapon blind I think the
battle rifle which is a feels completely
different but we're actually going to
have some more information coming about
new weapons in the game very soon today
actually that people were asking for you
know it's here we're going to be a g36
and and gun nerds probably know what
that is but that is happening
there's a lot of new stuff yep so
they're slowly getting rid of all of the
enemies yeah so and what we're looking
at here is one of the things we have an
underground sewer you know we see the
rail tracks you want to give you all the
kind of dark claustrophobic dangerous
faces you would expect underground show
but what we can do is play with you know
really tight spaces but also open it up
a bit let it breathe so again the
unpredictable element nice so you can
see state of chaos there's trash
everywhere I mean this is not the
underground you knew above or not at all
yeah and this does a fair degree of
exploration because we've seeded a lot
of collectibles that will expand the law
of the division within this mode too
nice so every time is generated you have
that possibility of falling on a
collector that you've never heard before
so audio logs a lot of audio logs some
visual mostly or Java
those four people are interested in
story those audio logs are going to
deepen the lore you know they're gonna
help explain in better detail what's
happening Ernie that's what happened
above all right we've also got herb X
which are you know photographs which
again will reveal an additional layer
what's going on well they will they
touch on characters that we already know
and as well or you'll have to go down
all right I got to find out damn it all
right fine so when we get rid of this
loss enemy it would be great if we can
open up the megamouth
all right well and a weekly objective hi
what I would recommend now is that we
quit this mission go back to the
Tactical Operations Center may be
launched something a little bit all
right yeah guys I think this is a bit
too easy for you you guys sure each week
should we try another all right okay all
right yannick let's call it there all
right so I don't know how far we want to
push it well once we get back to the
effects of the operations say that we
can we can figure out what exactly we
want to go with that well alright so I
actually going to bring I think the
audience in on this one and we're gonna
we're gonna see how crazy we can make
this if you guys are up for it people
would it what do you think oh you don't
want to see her it's not gonna go well I
Robert a hero's not gonna will go well
it's not gonna go out but you can see
this all right put your ID anak put it
on heroic do it I love it this is gonna
go terribly by the way our restaurant
didn't guess for 213 all rights to 11
yeah all right I'm gonna sleep no I know
this is gonna be bad all right to face
operation sure we're not gonna get that
far but all right and fog of oil let's
do it that's the mini-map one so waste
not want not that's the ammunition one
what sir yeah enemies won't drop a
munitions yes you have to be careful
with what you shoot and use those
support stations enemies do not drop em
oh and yours and you're starting mo
cameras reduce and if you reload and you
still have mo lift in that you lose your
new yeah yeah that's gone alright that's
gonna be cool mad skills what do we have
some mad skills that oh yeah does the
cooldowns for your skills ever gone to
this Yannick turn them all on let's do
all right sure okay all right so you
your guts to fight with us this is gonna
be her eNOS all right confirm it when
it's go there's one haha let's go all
right you guys are gonna have to go yeah
pretty carefully into into the night all
right okay so you'll notice that the
first rule in fact is completely
different from the last one yes this is
the user the tech system the machine
behind the game that's already stitched
this together yeah and is presenting
something so already we see we have a
different objective you know which one
is finally located safety of agent and
get that valuable data that they have
with them yeah and I think we're trying
to do is really thread a theme
throughout these operational so if it's
about defending you're gonna be
defending on throughout so yeah okay so
we have those get anybody out and we're
already suffer yeah yeah cool all right
if they can I lost my travels consider
this a success this has been so easy so
far you guys are doing great fans
oh my god
are they did gimmick gimmick room linux
just get out of there
something like this come on Liv run
Yannick revive you to know you can do it
alright so surely you guys can see that
this really does scale super high level
35 shot gunners if you guys aren't
scared of all right so new incursion
neuter she a little bit about this
absolutely so we've got Falcon we've got
clear skies and the next one is called
Dragon's nest okay that sounds very
ominous it's the first one against the
cleanness oh you are a lot of people's
favorite faction right favorite son
least favorite depending on how you look
at it favorite to fight off again and it
happens in a bus terminal Costa Times
Square it's a very very famous bus
terminal and your mission will be to go
in there and to clean them all out
because they've been regrouping they've
they've lost their leader Joe Pharaoh
yep but they regrouping under four new
leaders these four new leaders super
iconic very tough and they'll create a
different challenge each one of them you
have to approach in a different way but
you fight them you fight them yes Lily
all right and the final sort of
impossible challenge within the
incursion is a modified fire truck that
spits fire so not a literal dragon but a
metaphor dragon absolutely that's right
like it would have been crazy since like
an actual grave yeah be a bit of those
yes I think so too alright so I mean
what else are we getting from this
incursion and the subject is officer new
gear sit but we saw some of those just
before there's new weapons there's a
bunch of stuff I'm really excited for
this update obviously again and I
mentioned this before I've community
have been very vocal about the game and
that criticism often is very very
helpful to us yeah absolutely I mean of
course we read the Ubisoft forums you
push things that you're passionate about
to towards the team with very attentive
to what people are saying
okay we're about ready to hand off I
just want to say again thank you to
everyone and I think we also need to
give a shout out to to to Jannik my
other half 55 as well that was very
brave of them to show that uh yeah I
jacking it up on the oberoi because if
it is very very brave it's absolutely
yeah and again like us but you saw I
didn't it did not go very very well
alright I think we're about ready to
hand over okay thank you again guys for
coming out